foreign
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists oh what a special episode we
have today we are simplifying everything
of course we've got malabama here hi
everybody TK Coleman it's a beautiful
day and we've got the rest of our team
in the studio here as well coming up
today on this free public minimal
episode we're talking to a listener
about digital clutter and the many forms
that clutter takes on and the ways that
we can simplify everything then during
our lightning round we're going to talk
about attachment and why do I yearn for
so much stuff we also have a great live
stream question for you and a listener
tip you can check out the full two hour
maximal edition of episode 394 where we
answer five times the questions and we
dive deep into several simple living
segments now private podcast episode is
out right now at patreon.com the
minimalists your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free because say with me
y'all
advertisements suck yes they do let's
start with our callers if you have a
question or comment for our show please
give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists.com our first
question today is from Pete in the UK I
used more data online and found two
interesting programs
the internet's dirty Secret
and is the cloud damaging the planet
everything we stream and store is kept
in huge water and energy guzzling data
super service centers
some are bigger than the largest
stadiums
the carbon emissions are huge
I got home and decluttered my data and
storage as much as possible
photos videos emails and so on and so on
everything
essential
I saved a hard copy
and a question popped into my head
how could Our Lives
and the planet be better with less
are we just moving and dumping our stuff
elsewhere
Pete I think this is an astute
observation quite often what happens is
we trade one form of clutter for another
so clutter accumulates whenever
something gets in the way that means
digital clutter accumulates whenever our
technology gets in the way one way that
it gets in the way is yes we are
creating huge carbon emissions that we
never see we never think about there are
a lot of things that we don't think
about and because we don't think about
them they're good reasons sometimes we
can't think about everything if we see
500 000 discrete bits of information
over the course over the next hour I
can't possibly think about all of it I
remember a few years ago there was this
Vice documentary where they showed the
Korea North Korean labor camps that are
in Siberia did you ever see this no and
what they do is they're they're there
it's essentially slave labor and they're
cutting down all these trees in Siberia
because that there's a lot of trees
there and then those trees make the
their way to the more developed world
places especially like where Pete is in
the UK a lot of their wood comes from
slave labor in Siberia North Korean
slave labor in Siberia right and yet we
don't think about that when we build a
house it's like well I need some wood we
just buy the wood from the lumber yard
not even thinking about where it comes
from right and I think quite often what
happens is we open up this hole and we
begin to simplify Our Lives just like
Pete has done he's noticed oh I've got
all this other clutter I started dealing
with the physical clutter but what about
this technology clutter that's in my
life all of this digital clutter and
what are the effects of my clutter the
Clutter that I've created with my
physical things I've thrown away all
these Goods all the carbon emissions
that are associated with that but then
also what about my digital clutter what
about my financial clutter what about my
relationship clutter anytime I have
behaved like a total jerk in a
relationship I've cluttered up the
relationship and there are knock-on
effects of that that Ripple goes much
much farther than you might realize Ryan
do you remember back in the day when we
were in the corporate world we had a
boss it was just Tyrant yeah he was mean
to everyone and what I noticed after a
period of time the first year or so
other people that worked for him began
to mimic him oh yeah I was one of them I
mean I looked up to it it was confidence
and you know when you uh when you scare
people in in a meeting of 20 people
um you know it's it's like you dominate
the room
um yeah I think uh I think it's
interesting how my I guess maybe that's
my 22 year old ego who's just like oh I
want to go into a room and and people uh
look up to me and and be scared of me
but uh but he he uh he didn't last too
long at the company well he lasted long
enough to create a lot of damage oh yeah
yeah Bulls on a china shop might not
last that long in the china shop but as
soon as he exits the thing is destroyed
right yeah and in the wake of that the
difference with human beings or with our
technology and that's why I'm bringing
this up for Pete the difference is when
we create clutter there are knock-on
effects that we are not going to
anticipate one of the questions we ask
and it's not the only question worth
asking is does this add value to my life
and that's a great place to start
because quite often what I find and what
Peter's found is many of the things that
we tell ourselves a story about value oh
yes I am getting immense value from my
Twitter account really am I and just
because I'm getting some value from a
thing doesn't mean that is the best use
of my time and when we start simplifying
Our Lives when we simplify everything
from our physical Goods to our
relationships our digital clutter our
calendars the time consumerism that's
going on in our lives when we begin to
simplify our finances we realize like oh
wait a minute
the effects of the Clutter I've been
producing they begin to stop once I
simplify it's not about becoming perfect
though TK because yes to be the perfect
minimalist I've got down to my 100 items
I've removed all social media from my
life I no longer have a TV or any
digital screen that clutters my life at
all no of course not because each
person's life is going to look different
and my version of the simple life might
look cluttered to you or vice versa
that's exactly right I love your phrase
add value because the way you add value
the way you get to Simplicity isn't by
demonizing consumption but it's by
divinizing creativity right it's it's
how are you leveraging your acts of
consumption and employing those things
in the creative process like the way you
get waste is you consume and then you
use that constructively and whatever
can't be used constructively that's
what's left over as a waste and so waste
isn't just the result of consumption
it's the result of not not taking what
we consume and using it in a way that
adds value to other people that
expresses generosity and so what I see
what I see happening so much is we're
being sold this vision of happiness that
says you will get that life of
fulfillment by acquiring this or buying
this and what's left out of the story
it's what you do with this it's the
meaning that you give to this your
objects can't make you happy it's that
human capacity to contextualize these
objects by using them in a way that's
meaningful that's what's leading to all
this waste man Pete is like really
talking to my heart here because like I
think about the environment a lot I
don't talk about it a lot on the podcast
because to be honest I don't know how to
talk about it because it's like every
time I hear people talk about the
environment it is like all of this Doom
and Gloom and if we don't do this then
you know the planet's gonna be gone in
30 years or you know whatever prediction
it is but there is like a legitimate
problem with uh like plastic in the
ocean there's a legitimate problem with
um no matter where you go in the world
you could go like in the middle of
nowhere none of it in Canada and do some
topsoil testing and like there's lead in
there because we um because we have
polluted the Earth so it's like we are
poisoning ourselves and even me talking
about it is Doom and Gloom and it's and
it's like I don't want to just be
another Doom and Gloom voice but I don't
know like uh I don't know TK what do you
think man how do we talk about the
environment without it being uh you know
threatening the way you just did it you
just did it perfectly because you didn't
prophesy Doom and Gloom uh to prophesy
Doom and Gloom is to presuppose that you
have a certain amount of knowledge about
what's going to happen all you did was
honestly articulate the problem you've
expressed how that problem disturbs you
you admit it that you don't know all the
answers you acknowledge these questions
are important we need more conversations
like that rather than conversations
where people feel like they need to
pretend to be an expert on everything
just because they have a podcast yeah
yeah and you know it's interesting like
we can all do our part and uh and I
think that's important I mean you know
Mariah and I we do what we can I'm not
going to sit here and say like I'm the
perfect environmentalist at home but so
the thing is is like you can do your
part but I right now I think the most
important thing for people to do is uh
besides doing their part I guess is
supporting new systems that uh that
change the way that we basically
distribute Goods make Goods use Goods um
consume Goods whatever examples
so uh I you know like like right now
pretty much um everything is made in
China right like a lot of a lot of
things are so there's a lot of carbon
emitted because of and this isn't even a
carbon conversation but there's just a
lot of resources used up to get
everything over from China to the rest
of the world so uh changing the system
like one thing would be is like okay
let's how can we make American Goods
again how can we like you know at least
prevent that um that much traveling
needing to be done that's just one
example I'm not educated on this topic
so I can't sit here unless 15 maybe I
should have just talked about what I did
at home because now I'm getting down a
conversation I don't know how to talk
about but but no um you know I I think
that there are or other things that we
could potentially look at the question
is like how to support it that's the
next question right which I I don't
necessarily understand how to do but um
I don't know man how would you how do
you talk about the environment without
without the Doom and Gloom stuff I think
whenever something feels overwhelming
we tend to throw our hands up and that's
kind of where Pete is right now this
isn't really a conversation about the
environment it is a conversation about
pain and suffering and part of that has
something to do with the environment and
the story he's telling himself now is
the reason to not use technology is
because it overwhelms the environment
but truly what is overwhelmed here is
Pete he's overwhelmed by technology in
so many other ways outside of the
environment he's glummed on to one thing
about the environment and understandably
so it's it's Noble to to not want to
pollute other people's lives totally get
that right but right now well I think
what he's noticing is his life has been
polluted with technology yeah and it
doesn't mean getting all technology out
of your life and living like the Amish
who by the way still use their version
of Technology right they have wagons
that's technology right they have tools
that is technology it just may not be
the glowing screens that we have and so
even they have some sort of a of
omissions in their life and what we're
doing here when we use technology
and we have excess emissions that's from
not using our technology deliberately
and that's ultimately what we're talking
about when we talk about simplifying our
entire lives it starts with the stuff
that's the initial bite at the Apple
that tends to change everything with
respect to minimalism because the stuff
is so overwhelming you could see it so
easily but then there's all this hidden
clutter we did a whole episode about
hidden clutter and part of it's the
technology part of it's that calendar
clutter that you're struggling with you
know I'm busy I'm busy I'm busy I'm
spending so much time doing things that
other people think are important and now
it's urgent for me well that's hidden
clutter in a different way and all of
these types of clutter are overwhelming
and they make us not act at all they
make us continue to go with the flow or
worse because what Pete's experience
here you know what there's nothing I can
do and as soon as you say there's
nothing I can do to fix the big thing
what you're really saying is there's
nothing I can do in my own life to fix
my own problems as well yeah and it
might be more accurate to say there is
nothing that I currently know how to do
because there's always more that we
don't know than what we do know and if
we were able to find out what we don't
know it might change our opinions about
what we can do so the best we can say is
I'm unable to do anything right now
because I don't know how to do anything
about it but maybe I can learn something
new and I can change things Pete I want
to acknowledge you for taking the life
the simple Road the the simple road to
the simple life
um yeah it's interesting when we start
to raise the standards of our lives our
uh our standards change uh in the sense
of how we see things so this happens
when
um you know I remember I was like one of
the heaviest points in my life I started
losing weight started working out and I
started uh looking in the mirror and
instead of seeing someone who was
looking better I was like oh I need to
keep going because I'm still not where I
want to be and this happens with our
stuff when you start to live a more
clutter-free life you start to notice
clutter more so uh yeah Pete keep keep
up the great work man Pete I want to
invite you we are and I'm going to talk
about this later in the episode during
the right here right now segment but we
are launching our first ever
decluttering course that's all we called
this episode simplify everything because
the course itself is called simplify
everything we didn't want to just
deal with the stuff well that's the
first week it's a five-week course we go
through all of your stuff we give you a
bunch of deeper understandings about
your physical clutter your digital
clutter your calendar clutter your
financial clutter and your relationship
clutter there are 45 clutter problem
areas that we identify
135 decluttering Solutions and so a good
chunk of that one week of that has to do
with your digital clutter that's why I
thought Pete's question was ideal yeah
for this episode simplify
everything.xyz we're going to give you a
access to that course Pete and this is a
three-day thing only uh I think it's 72
hours starting today May 29th 2023 it's
available for three days open enrollment
right now let's move on to some social
media questions looks like we got a
question from Maha on Facebook how can I
stop being so attached to things and why
do I get so attached to things
the million dollar answer just read all
our books watch our documentaries listen
to all our podcasts and here's the order
you have to do it in you know to let go
you don't have to do anything except
stop the clinging now obviously the
first step in that is not to just drop
something if you have a really tight
grip on something for a really long time
if I got my my device here and I'm just
clinging to it clinging to it
not saying throw it across the room the
first thing I need to do is just this is
kind of painful when I cling for a while
right in fact we're going to get into
this later on the private podcast I've
got this video example of the pain that
is caused by clinging so the first step
is not to just throw this or drop it
it's to Simply loosen my grip for a
second I'm still holding it now without
that same tension I can ask does this
add value to my life
is this getting in the way
is this serving its purpose or did it
already serve its purpose and if it
served its purpose before I'm clinging
to it because it's residue from the past
it's never going to do for me the thing
it did before the story I'm telling
myself is yes maybe it added value a
year ago a decade ago but
I'll hold on to it just in case
and now I'm clinging to it again I feel
myself clean tighter I oh moves to my
grip okay how do I let go
I simply cease the clinging and
if it was a
snake in your hand you wouldn't ask how
do I let go of the snake you don't need
a three-step process to stop clinging as
soon as you realize you understand how
dangerous the thing you're clinging to
is how dangerous clinging in general is
because it keeps you Tethered to a place
you don't want to be
you drop it automatically yeah
you know I I think it's important to
highlight the fact that attraction
precedes attachment the reason we're
attached to things is because at some
point we were genuinely sincerely and
legitimately attracted to it and that
attraction turned into an addiction or a
codependent relationship and instead of
making the leap to try to figure out how
can I break up with this attachment
you've got to ask yourself well what's
legitimate about the attraction that
underlies the attachment because you
can't figure out how to meet a desire in
a healthy way if you don't Embrace that
fundamental desire as healthy and as
good and so often we attack ourselves by
saying oh I'm such a filthy person for
filling this way I'm such a bad person
for having a taste for that for being
drawn to that attracted to that wanting
that and we're so busy condemning
ourselves that we never learn from the
wisdom of our attractions and our
affinities but when you place yourself
before those attractions and say well
what what are you teaching me what needs
are you meeting for me then you can say
all right I'm ready to let go of the
unhealthy unsustainable way of doing
those things and I'm ready to do those
things in a way that lines up with my
highest values yeah and I think that
works TK because you're finding purpose
and you're finding meaning
beyond your things and that's I mean
that's why we get attached to our things
like we're all looking for purpose and
meaning and it's very very easy to look
at uh things from the past uh things
from our you know grandfather or great
great grandfather and uh makes us feel
good and there's nothing wrong with that
but if that's what the if the things
that we have in our lives are the only
thing that bring us meaning like that's
why you're having such a difficult time
letting go yeah you have a difficult
time letting go because of exactly what
Ryan just said if you're not in the
moment you're in the past or you're in
the future and you're telling yourself
some Doom story about the future
because you want to let go of the past
and so when I think about the things
that I've clung to you never cling in
the present moment the example I always
love to use with my daughter when she's
on the monkey bars climbing across and
she's truly present what happens there's
a cycle of attachment and letting go
she's not clinging in perpetuity there's
a brief moment of attachment necessary
attachment holding on for just as long
as she needs to move forward but when we
cling what happens you can't move
forward it could be a bunch of excess
books if you cling to those it's
difficult to move forward if you have a
bunch of clothes you don't wear anymore
and you're clinging to those you can't
move forward maybe you have a career you
just don't enjoy anymore if you don't
enjoy it you can't be in the present
moment what does that mean you're
clinging to the career you're not able
to move forward what about the
relationships that are from your past
that are no longer serving you or you're
no longer able to serve them if you're
holding on to those out of a Pious sense
of obligation you're clinging you can't
move on to more meaningful relationships
we cling in all these other areas of our
life it's not just the material Goods
it's easy to see the things that we
cling to but mentally we're clinging to
everything from our past the only time
we don't cling to the past is when we're
living right here right now in the
present moment yeah just to add to that
real quick you've got to know what
you're moving forward towards
like that's that is what is going to
help you let go a little bit more that's
why she can do the monkey bar she sees
the destination she knows exactly when
she needs to cling and like oh clang and
let go but if you blindfold her be a
little bit different probably
and that clinging for the moment she's
not actually cleaning she's attaching
herself to it and she's able to let go
because she knows the direction in which
she's going she may not know the
ultimate destination the ultimate
arrival point and that's totally fine
but she knows where the next Monkey Bar
is yeah and that is onward moving
forward in order to move forward just a
little bit you have to let go and I bet
you if you blindfolded Ella she probably
could do the monkey bars blindfolded
she's pretty athletic
Ryan what time is it you know what time
it is it's time for the lightning round
where we answer your questions from Tick
Tock yes indeed you can follow the
minimals on Tick Tock also Instagram
Facebook and Twitter at the minimalist
during the lightning round we each have
60 seconds to answer your questions with
a short shareable less than 140
character response we put the text to
these minimal maxims in the show notes
over at the minimalists.com podcast so
you can copy and share our pithy answers
on social media if you'd like today's
question is from veggies and bread I
have clothes that are thin and have
holes in them but I don't want to throw
them away if they can't be donated how
else can we recycle old clothes
ladies and gentlemen Ryan Nicodemus has
60 seconds on the clock what's pithy for
him Nicodemus there is no honor in
clinging to things that no longer add
value to your life and I've seen this so
many times where people hold on to
things because they see it as honorable
I'm not putting it in the landfill and
when you're doing that you're just
letting it decompose on your shelf and
you can choose to let those things
decompose wherever you want but clinging
has no honor yeah and one might even say
it's dishonorable in a way because
you're disrespecting yourself through
all that clinging ladies and gentlemen
TK Coleman
your clutter is the solution to someone
else's problem it's the answer to
someone else's question and it's the
tool that someone else needs for very
important work that they need to do no
matter what it is you possess when
you're ready to let it go there's
something you can do to transform it or
to give it to another person and help
them fulfill a dream with it and that's
also true of these clothes that you no
longer want to wear but that you can't
donate where there's a will there is
always a way to recycle always yes yes
so I can walk you through some practical
things but first let me give you
something pithy the most sustainable
item is the item that is left on the
Shelf the reason we have so many things
that end up in a landfill is we go out
and consume so many things we buy so
many things we bring so many things home
that quickly become excess we buy
something not understanding the true
cost of the thing yes there's the price
tag on the thing but then there's the
environmental cost there's the storage
costs the psychological costs the
cleaning calls the upgrading call so now
I have to put apps on the thing or
change the batteries in the thing or put
oil in the thing or whatever it might be
there are all of these additional costs
and so if you want to be sustainable
leave it on the Shelf unless it's
absolutely essential for your life if
it's truly going to add value great
bring it home but if you're just
bringing it home bringing it home all
the time guess what happens you end up
with 81 pounds of clothing every year
that you throw away if you're the
average American let me get real
practical for a second though because I
will put a link in the show notes to one
thing I have an article here called the
25 best places to recycle old clothes
that cannot be donated I'm not going to
walk you through all of those because
this is the lightning on right now but
if you head on over to the
minimalists.com podcast we'll put a link
to that article the 25 best places to
recycle old clothes that cannot be
donated however here's something I have
for you
clothes can be recycled question mark
here are five underrated ways to use old
clothes that cannot be donated so it's
true that if you have a lot of old
clothes many of our old clothes still
have tags on them donate those let
someone else get value from them or in a
gently used clothes yeah you can donate
those to your local Goodwill or local
homeless shelters that you can sell them
on eBay I like buy a lot of my shirts
from eBay now because and I'll get them
they're either brand new or the worn
ones didn't fit me well I'm gonna sell
it great it's essentially new at that
point except the price is like fifty
percent ninety percent less than what it
would have been however if you've got a
bunch of clothes that can't be donated
at this point instead of just throwing
them away here are five things you can
do the first thing is I'll put a link to
this article in the show notes as well
first thing you can do is cut or tear
your old clothes up and make them into
Rags for cleaning I've done that a bunch
I mean yeah that makes sense right I
mean they're essentially Rags we even
use that term now right oh look at these
old rags yeah I'll turn them into Rags
that's pretty simple you can dye the
fabric and turn it into something usable
like a hair elastic that's what TK does
or a headband
for those listening it's funny because
he does not have hair on his head
the joke's not funny you have to explain
it Mallory
good night for those who did not get the
joke it was the basis for the humor was
that he's actually bald and visit
Mallory's website jokesexplained.com
the third thing on the list here is use
the textiles as pillow stuffing I
already have stuff in my pillow so I
probably don't need that wear old
stained or damaged clothing for painting
projects or other dirty tasks like yard
work however Ryan be careful with that
because we can justify holding on to
anything oh yeah I did work around the
house and um when I was living in Ohio
and I had you know 20 work shirts and 20
work pairs of jeans and
um I could only wear so many of those
layers at once go back to the pillow
thing though Mariah actually did this
because she bought a pillow that had a
bunch of plastic inside of it oh she
didn't realize it it's because it was
like you know the I was just like it
wasn't microplastic but it was some kind
of plastic that she had so she like took
all the filling out we stuffed it with
old clothes oh wow yeah okay so it is
practical very practical and finally
practice sewing or patch repair this is
what Ella does at her unschool they just
have a bunch of old donated clothes
there and she's messing them all up
sewing things together she's so enclosed
to her hands sometimes but the point is
that if you are wanting to pick up that
skill you're going to need some clothes
that you're able to ruin before you can
get better at it that's a great idea
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes as well we'll check out the
patreon live stream in a moment but
first real quick for right here right
now here's one thing that's going on in
the life of the minimalist three days
only starting today which is the 29th of
May 2023 so three days 72 hours we are
launching our first ever decluttering
course come on
dude we work so hard on this thing oh my
God I might say we I mean Jordan
a lot this is been going on since last
year we started planning it and outlying
it last year it's called simplify
everything it starts with the stuff it's
five weeks that first week we get deep
into your physical clutter but then
beyond that we have a week of digital
clutter we have a week of calendar
clutter I'm so busy I don't know what to
do I keep saying yes yes yes or we help
you with the calendar clutter as well
and then of course Financial clutter do
you have any debt in your life do you
make any irrational or impulse purchases
we help out with financial clutter and
ultimately we end the course with
relationship clutter 17 video lessons 45
clutter problem areas 135 decluttering
Solutions a 30 page workbook student
forums and much much more of less it is
called simplify everything you can find
it at simplify everything dot x y z Ryan
earlier you mentioned your favorite part
was the the relationship clutter a week
because it all sort of builds up to that
what really stood out to you throughout
the course is there any memories as you
were filming it and re-filming it and
re-re-filming it yeah no uh yeah a lot
of memories
um I learned a lot of lessons along the
way like speaking straight to camera is
very different than having a
conversation on a podcast
um so I became much better at uh
learning what I need to do to talk
directly to camera oh he's being bashful
right now like Ryan stole the show when
you go to that first week you're like oh
my gosh do I need to redo everything
because it was like we were one-upping
each other like you know when three
people get a song and they have three
different verses and like they're each
trying to one-up the next person I
wasn't intentionally doing that but then
Ryan comes in and I'm like oh my gosh
his new take is so good what am I
supposed to do with this yeah like once
I learned what I had to do and got my
footing like I do feel really good about
it I have never ever watched anything of
mine and have been like oh Mariah you
got to see this of me until this course
look how awesome this came out anyway I
looked at you and I was like man will I
look like this
the uh the relationships piece of it the
reason why I think that's my most
favorite part is because this is like
one of the most difficult things for us
to deal with toxic relationships people
at work how do we live up to other
people's expectations like those are
things that um I think people will find
a lot of value in um because like me
like I hey I want to say yes to
everything I hate telling people no
um and I want to over commit all the
time and I want to make everybody happy
and it's taking a lot of work to um not
just feed into those impulses that I
have and I know a lot of people out
there probably have those impulses that
they could use a little support on I
really like the first week because what
it does it distills down in one week
three video lessons each video Lesson
has 14 different segments in it and what
it does it still down like 13 14 years
of what we have learned collectively and
puts it in a way that is really useful
these boundaries that we help people set
up in their own lives and the idea is
you walk away from each video with nine
Solutions in each video but one that you
can apply to your life today and then
you can build on it from there however
my favorite weeks were the digital
clutter of week because a lot of hidden
clutter there right with social media in
particular or our glowing screens our
televisions and we give some practical
ways in our own life our own recipes for
simplifying the digital clutter and then
I really enjoyed the third week I think
that was probably my favorite week
because it was about calendar clutter I
think that's the biggest form of hidden
clutter we have this micro clutter it's
kind of like micro plastic you don't
realize that it's in your water and
everything else whenever I say yes to
something I'm adding a little bit of
clutter and it's not about going around
now and saying no no no I'm not going to
do this but it's about understanding
that every yes is a form of clutter and
we show some ways to better understand
that kind of calendar clutter that's
making us miserable but also give some
practical ways to eliminate a lot of
that clutter TK what about you my
favorite section was the calendar
clutter because it really
forced me to dig in into just how much
busyness is applied in our society right
it it's a badge of honor and it's an
excuse for not being the people we want
to be and for so many of us we feel like
we have these grandiose or satisfying
visions of how we could be living Our
Lives if we weren't so busy and yet we
have a hard time letting go of the
stories around why we're busy and so I
think we provide a lot of value in that
calendar clutter section that resonates
with me very strongly and and what I see
a lot of people out there struggling
with well the website is simplify
everything.xyz the.com was not available
but I figured this is appropriate anyway
right XYZ we're going to get to the end
of your clutter simplify everything.xyz
it's a five-week course however it's
available for 72 hours only May 29th May
30th May 31st and then if you're
listening to this after that you can
held on over there put your email
address and if we decide to offer this
again in the future I don't know but uh
my hope is this goes really well we
learn a lot of lessons from this a lot
of hard work went into this so if you'd
like to join you can join simplify
everything dot x y z
let's check in with our patreon live
stream see what else we got here hey
what's what's your best question you got
for us from Alabama oh they're all so
good it's hard to pick one uh let's go
with marvette's question I want to let
go of the need to be productive as a
justification for being or doing what
isn't my true desire but I still feel
expected to fit into societal Norms why
do we participate in so many things that
don't truly matter to us and why do we
feel compelled to do so because it does
matter to you on some level right with
your the approval of other people
matters to you it doesn't have to matter
to you by the way you get to choose what
matters and what doesn't matter to you
or if you don't choose it guess what
happens exactly where you're at right
now people hand you what is going to be
important oh this is important to me so
now I'm going to make it important to
you I'm going to make it important to
you here's how you should behave you
should go to college you should graduate
from a prestigious school you should
make a six-figure salary you should own
a car and oh by the way it should be a
nice car and you should wear a suit
every day or you should wear these kinds
of clothes you should have logos on your
handbag you should you should you should
we're shooting all over ourselves
because something does matter to you and
if it because if it didn't matter to you
then you wouldn't you wouldn't allow it
to happen because there are certain
things you wouldn't do even if it got
you the approval of others earlier we
were talking on the private podcast
about the having a button on the table
and if you press that button everyone in
Switzerland dies
you're not going to do that well why
aren't you going to do it you're not
going to do it because it doesn't matter
to you you don't want everyone in
Switzerland to die right but if you
press the button on the table and
everyone your family is now happy right
you're going to do that why because it
matters to you however it is not your
job to make them happy it is your job to
understand what makes you happy and to
exclude everything else yeah when I
think about those horror movies sci-fi
depictions of moments in which people
sell their souls
it's always the same the devil shows
them this Grand Vision of what life
could be like you see that beautiful
person over there I'll cause them to
fall in love with you you see all of
those riches over there I'll give this
to you if you only give me your soul and
we watch these shows and we think ah I
would never do something like that if
the devil showed up on my doorstep but
the devil shows up every day on
everyone's doorstep in the form of a
world that's constantly promising to
love you if you compromise your
authenticity for their acceptance I
promise to love you if you stop telling
the jokes that you think are funny and
you tell the ones that I think are safe
I promise to love you Josh if you stop
writing what you really believe and you
word it in the exact way I'm telling you
to word it why don't I write my own
stuff by the way if I'm writing to you
about how you should write I promise to
love you if you date this person or If
you deny this or if you forget your
political beliefs and have the ones that
I want you to have but the world is
lying to you it will not love you if you
conform yourself to it it will cease to
respect you and then find another reason
to hate you the reason why you don't
want to spend your life justifying
yourself to people is because the kind
of people who demand that you justify
yourself before they can love you they
are lying to you and they will never
love you their power comes from making
you squirm when they say Justify Your
Existence to me and once you take that
away from them they're not going to
appreciate that they're going to take
their power right back and say well
squirm over this dance for me I don't
like that dance do a different dance
you're never going to find peace in that
do what you want to do for you and let
the world hate you for reasons that
matter to you because if you're going to
be hated you better get something out of
the deal yeah for sure dang that's good
I uh real quick I would go back to that
question I asked Jules who told you this
who told you that this was the standard
who told you that people expected this
of you
um I would go a little bit deeper and be
like why did you tell yourself that are
you modeling someone are you modeling
someone you look up to like I did the
Tyrant that we used to work with um
and if it's because you are modeling
someone do you actually want to model
that person yeah is that the person I
actually want to be yeah it's funny when
you model someone what you often
discover is as you get closer to them
you are modeling a 2d version even if
it's you want to be Michael Jordan or
you want to be Lawrence Fishburne or
something you get closer to them you
realize I don't want all of their recipe
I want a few little nuggets from them
and that's okay but if I need to be just
like someone else that I'm not myself at
all and that's not an authentic desire
that's a a virus for a societal virus
that you've caught I need to be like
them in order to be accepted well who
said you need to be accepted in the
first place we'll check back in with the
live stream here in a little bit but
first malabama what else you got for us
here's a minimalist Insight from one of
our listeners
hi this is Nancy from Iowa my 91 year
old mother who lives in a senior
apartment complex stayed at my home for
Christmas we watched some DVDs that my
minimalist Millennial children watched
years ago these Disney movies musicals
and teen comedies were things that she
had never seen before she laughed a lot
and it got me thinking that most seniors
in her complex had not seen these
lighthearted comedies and musicals
either we boxed up all of the movies my
children loved but now stream instead
and donated them to the senior complex
for their weekly movie Nights these
movies are now also seen in the
neighboring nursing home
all right y'all that's our minimal
episode for today we'll see you on
patreon for the full two hour maximal
edition of episode 394 which includes
answers to a bunch more questions like
how can I be a minimalist if the people
I live with are messier than me what's
the most annoying advertisement you've
ever seen how can I better understand
the pain of not letting go plus a
million more questions also this week a
private minimalist home tour from one of
our listeners it's a blissful Swedish
dining room I'm going to talk about what
I would change in this dining room if it
were my dining room and why I don't
recommend that she changes it at all
look at all that plus much much more of
less and if you want to hear all that
check out the minimalist private podcast
at patreon.com the minimalist or click
the link in the description to subscribe
and get your personal link so that our
weekly maximal episodes play in your
favorite podcast app you'll also gain
access to all of our podcast archives
all the way back to episode zero zero
one and if you're still on the fence
here's a testimonial from one of our
lovely lovely patreon supporters pixie
says hey y'all I decided to join the
private podcast because I love to keep
my life advertisement free I'm grateful
for your varying perspectives on this
minimalist Journey pixie thank you so
much so much and thank you to all of our
patreon subscribers our supporters that
private podcast is really where it's at
it is time to try out the private
podcast patreon.com the minimalists and
if you leave here today with just one
message
please
[Music]
love people
and use things
because the opposite
ever works thanks for listening y'all
we'll see you next time peace
every little thing
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed or I bet that you'll
be fine without it